herzlich willkommen ja die macht meine
damen und herren die scheint überall zu
sein nicht nur in der politik und
wirtschaft sondern auch in der moral ja
sogar in der liebe und vermutlich auch
hier tisch zwischen mir und meinem
heutigen gast
martin sa ist professor für
sozialphilosophie an der goethe
universität in frankfurt am main und
einer der führenden experten wenn es um
fragen der macht geht herzlich
willkommen er sei ja für die nächste
stunde gilt sie sind der gast ich der
moderator wer von uns beiden hat denn
eigentlich mehr macht
ich würde jetzt gerne sagen auf jeden
fall sie weil sie die definition
definiert haben und weiterhin definieren
das heißt ich muss reagieren reagieren
müssen heisst natürlich sich auch
begeben in ein spiel in eine situation
und auch ein gefälle von
handlungsoptionen die erstmal die eine
person bestimmt aber auch das ist nicht
stabil das heißt ich werde versuchen
auch meine macht hier spielen und zu
ergreifen
ich meine sie können natürlich
ausweichen zu können ein stichwort geben
dass ich angreifen das heißt es ist
wirklich auch ein machtspiel zwischen
uns beiden wenn wir jetzt im folgenden
eine stunde lang über macht die
irritiert als es richtig und die
situation die wir jetzt gerade sehen die
deutlich sichtbar explizit es ist eine
sache eine hintergrund stehen andere
dinge die geschichte ihrer institution
meiner institution die reputation die
öffentliche meinung die bücher auch das
sind natürlich vielleicht kleine aber
doch ziemlich deutliche machtfaktoren
daher die macht ist da und nicht immer
nur da wo man sie sieht sondern sie es
auch in den hintergründen in den
voraussetzungen in den impliziten
elementen sehr interessant also
erwartungen der zuschauer in zuschauer
zum beispiel sind in unseren köpfen dann
habe ich hier so ein wurm drin oder
produzent ab und zu etwas sagen das
sieht man erst mal nicht
das heißt macht es etwas so bleiben es
etwas schwer fassbares aber was ist denn
eigentlich die macht in denen sie das
definieren wer als philosophen sind ja
zuständig für die allgemeinheit und ganz
ganz allgemein könnte natürlich sagen
macht ist wirkung
das heißt macht bezieht sich auf
wirkungs verhältnisse das heißt auf jede
situation in der dinge passieren von
denen man sagt sie werden nicht passiert
wenn bestimmte andere faktoren nicht da
gewesen wären und deswegen könnte man
ganz allgemein sagen wer über macht
spricht will wirkungs verhältnisse
beschreiben zb auch beeinflussung oder
manchmal auch dass jemandem zu etwas
bringen niemanden zu etwas führen das
kann bis zur manipulation bis zum zwang
gehen aber überall wo wir wirkungen
sehen die wir beschreiben auf denken
analysieren wollen ist der macht begriff
einschlägig ganz allgemein gesprochen
es gibt sehr unterschiedliche mittel die
wir verwenden können um etwas zu
beeinflussen und zu bewirken
und es gibt eine berühmte definition von
max weber dem berühmten soziologen auf
die sich viele viele sängerinnen und
denker beziehen und er definiert macht
als chance innerhalb einer sozialen
beziehung den eigenen willen auch gegen
widerstände wider schrieben
durchzusetzen
gleichviel worauf diese chance beruht
das heißt etwas bewirken egal womit das
kann gebaut sein das geld sein das kann
aber auch vernunft und gute argumente
seien
das ist richtig ist denn vernunft nicht
das gegenteil von macht das würden wir
denken wir würden denken die macht
beginnt dort wo die gründe die vernunft
die argumente aufhören wenn man so
allgemein übermacht denke ich es grad
vorgeschlagen habe alles was wirkungs
verhältnisse beschreibt ist macht dann
ist natürlich klar gibt es auch die
macht der gründe die macht der vernunft
die macht das argument und der
argumentation und dann würde man
natürlich sagen hat weber recht
gleichwohl worauf diese
durchsetzungsfähigkeit beruht und so
würde ich auch darüber denken ich würde
sagen am einen ende des spektrums liegt
mit liegen wahrscheinlich die nackten
machten
vielleicht sagt er die gewalt mittel die
zwangsmittel körperlicher stärke
durchsetzungsfähigkeit die fast physisch
verkörpert ist aber am anderen ende des
spektrums lägen wahrscheinlich auch
nicht nur kraft der sprache dass worte
sondern tatsächlich auch der gründe und
der vernunft und das würde heißen die
macht es selbst ein spektrum und
irgendwo am rand finden sich die
extremere der mitte finden sich die
interessanten zweifelsfälle und wann ist
ein argument das stechen der mann ist
die situation ist die manipulation die
verführung oder auch dass jemandem mit
allen möglichen mit einem arsenal von
machtmittel zu etwas bringen das
eigentliche phänomen und darüber
streiten die philosophin die philosophen
die politologen die soziologin und die
frage ist unerschöpflich
wenn also diese diese grenzfälle wo man
nicht weiß hat er nicht jetzt überzeugt
oder überreden
diese diese fälle aber erstmal die frage
was gewinnt man dann wenn man diesen
macht begriff so weit was das selbst ein
gutes argument ein machtmittel ist warum
macht man das
ich würde denken wir gewinnen gewisse
art von realismus in der einschätzung
der vielfältigkeit der macht wenn wir
denken würden nur der der zwingen kann
der stärker ist hat macht würden wir ja
sehr viele fälle in denen subtile macht
unsichtbare macht vielleicht auch
globalisierte macht herrscht gar nicht
mehr als macht beschreiben können und
das würde glaube ich unsere diagnose arm
machen auch im politischen gebremst das
sind die fälle von denen ich hier das
meistens denke daher erscheint es mir
erst mal sinnvoll zu sagen der weite
macht begriff spannt das spektrum so
weit auf dass es vielleicht ein bisschen
ungewohnt aber jetzt kann man ja die
differenzierung eintreiben eintragen das
heißt jetzt könnte man ja sagen jetzt
gibt es wahrscheinlich physische macht
man's macht manipulations macht aber es
gibt auch die zwischenfälle die
manipulation zur führungsmacht und
vielleicht sogar am anderen ende des
spektrums die vernünftigen träger oder
wo die originale macht und das scheint
mir attraktiv dass wir sagen der macht
begriff selber ist fundamental
grundsätzlich damit wage allgemein wie
die philosophie ja immer
und trotzdem erlaubt sie danach die
weitere fassung das macht begriffs
differenzierungen die verschiedene macht
typen verschiedene macht quellen
verschiedene macht medien erlauben zu
differenzieren und so denke ich ja
generell über philosophie muss ich sagen
sie beginnt bei den allgemeinen heiten
versucht sie aber danach zu
spezifizieren und dann natürlich auch
die vielfältige wirklichkeit passgenaue
könnte man sagen detailreich zu
beschreiben aber sie tut das mit den
allgemeinen begriffen der fachbegriff
hat für mich genau diesen rang zu
bringen ist der ist so fundamental wie
der begriff der vernunft oder denkens
oder des menschen und man sieht ihm
natürlich damit auch aus dieser negativ
besetzten ecke wenn man sagt selbst
vernunft ist ein macht mit und vernunft
ist etwas sehr positiv besetzt das dann
kann die macht sowohl etwas böses aber
dass
das seien jacob burckhardt wird die
redewendung von der ansicht bösen macht
zugeschrieben dass richter hat das
verwendet allerdings in einem eher
deskriptive kontext der historiker
christoph burkhard der gesagt hat wenn
ich mich recht erinnere macht es
deswegen immer böse weil wir immer mehr
davon wollen die man sehr und wir können
sich diese gier dahinter ozeanische
denkfigur aus dem 17ten jahrhundert das
was in den grund gehen menschen nach
mehr macht macht streben auf den namen
herrscht das stimmt er meistens denken
wir über macht als etwas negatives nicht
immer als etwas böses aber negatives wir
denken die macht blockiert oder
verhindert oder verbietet und die macht
theorien vor allem der zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts haben dieses bild ja enorm
verkompliziert und viele haben gesagt
dass es richtig macht kann markieren
verhindern verbieten aber es gibt auch
macht form die selber in sich etwas eher
produktives oder jetzt konstanter team
ist wie wir manchmal sagen haben und
auch das scheint mir richtig das macht
spektrum ist soweit das ist nicht nur
die blockade das abschneiden von
handlungen worauf weber übrigens eher
abzielt ein begreifen kann sondern auch
die anderen fälle und verführung
manipulation sind ja auch so
zwischenfälle der wird auch etwas
kreiert der werden auch psychologische
wirkungen ausgelöst die sind nicht an
sich nur negativ oder verhindern sondern
dann selber schöpferischer passiert
etwas wie in einer beziehung ergeben
sich auch neue dinge es ist nicht nur
eine art von beziehung in der
abgeschnitten oder negiert wird und auch
das macht die macht für die sophie
einerseits schwierig aber auch so
faszinierend weil sie diese spektrum und
diese option nur diese möglichkeiten
auch der neuschaffung versucht zu
begreifen und trotzdem den macht begriff
dafür verwenden will ist es nicht
irgendetwas was sie etwas schafft nicht
die kunst oder die freiheit sondern die
macht selber hat etwas zur folge was neu
ist und das ist ein enorm interessanter
gedanke
da man spürt schon sie sind fasziniert
von diesem thema und damit die denker
mit denen sie sich befasst haben
friedrich nietzsche michel foucault
spinosa die bücher die sie geschrieben
haben dass kreist immer um dieses thema
gemacht jetzt persönliche frage können
sie sich erinnern an einen moment eine
intensive erfahrung muss ich selbst
gespürt haben ich bin ohnmächtig oder
ich habe sehr viel macht und neige dazu
sie zu missbrauchen
die gefahr besteht also ist macht ihn
ihren persönlichen lebensthemen das wäre
jetzt lächerlich wenn ich das sagen
würde weil jedes menschen alltag
natürlich die ganze zeit an die grenzen
der macht aber auch an die möglichkeiten
der macht rührt das beginnt bei unserer
rolle in institutionen die durch und
durch vermachte in dem sind ist dass die
institution projekt was wir können nun
was wir nicht können in dem was sie
definiert wie wir vorhin über die
situation gesprochen hatten also sie als
professor an der universität in
frankfurt genau ist das bleiben wir mal
bei den beispiel sie sehe nicht welche
dem autobiographischen ein bisschen aus
in dieser rolle wird man ja sagen wer
hat hier die macht natürlich der
professor im seminarraum vorlesungsreihe
er ist ja der mitte reputation mit dem
wissen
aber wenn man genauer hinguckt der
professor ist dermaßen abhängig von
seinem publikum
und von denen die auf ihn reagieren von
denen die übrigens seine angebliche so
objektive macht annehmen wer die
reputation nicht kennt oder sie sogar
abgelehnt wird sie die macht nicht
bestätigen sondern im gegenteil wird sie
sogar bekämpfen
und prompt ist die bekämpfte macht eine
die gar nicht mehr so ohne weiteres wird
plötzlich ist sie in ihrer bestritten
bereit etwas fragiles gedanke der beiden
relativ große rolle spielt dass die
macht natürlich nur dann wirksam ist wo
sie tatsächlich anerkannt wird wenn die
anerkennung fehlt wird auch diese macht
interessanterweise ihre halt oder
plötzlich nicht mehr objektiv und das
sind phänomene die interessieren mich
glaube ich in der tat schon seit langem
die interessieren mich natürlich auch in
bezug auf andere phänomene die macht der
religion ist hier zum beispiel auch für
mich auch biografisch nicht ganz und
regen des phänomen individuell sein dass
natürlich auch die kirchlichen
institution eine art von autorität sich
erwerben
zu der sich die macht des denkens sind
im gewissen sinn erst mal verhalten muss
weil das ist eine andere art von gründen
unsere art von autorität die hier
behauptet wird setzte sich sehr religiös
aufgewachsen und haben das dann in einem
religiösen kontext der haben zumal
gelände zu sagen und auch das war für
mich eine interessante erfahrung dass
unterschiedliche bereiche oder
unterschiedliche form mit etwas
umzugehen zu denen für mich die
philosophie irgendwann auch gehört hat
sozusagen in konkurrenz steht mit
anderen sphären und anderen bereichen in
denen andere argumente bezugspunkte oder
mittel mächtig oder wirksam sind als
andere und ich glaube diese konkurrenz
oder pluralität nicht nur von macht
quellen sondern auch sagen wir mal macht
registern
das ist eine grunderfahrung von der ich
glaube dass sie mich auch geprägt hat
das andere ist dass ich sehr früh und
vielleicht sogar in der nische lektüre
das kann ich aber gar nicht so
zurückverfolgen gemerkt habe dass der
macht begriff obwohl er so speziell
wirkt als etwas spezifisches über
gesellschaften oder politik eigentlich
ein durch und durch grundsatzthemen der
philosophie und jetzt
geistesgeschichtliche ist da tatsächlich
die dünnes vorstellung von aristoteles
ist so der grund auf dem wir viel so
zurückführen
das heißt die abendländische kultur
spricht eigentlich von anfang an ab dem
moment an dem sich spricht und
schriftliche zeugnisse hat übermacht in
verschiedenen begriffen in den
verschiedenen vokabular und das war für
mich irgendwann ein sehr starkes jetzt
auch für meine eigene arbeit prägen das
interesse diese unterschiedlichkeiten
dieser vokabular oder dieser
semantischen der macht nach zu verwenden
ich möchte mit ihnen noch ein bisschen
bei den persönlichen bleiben beim
psychologischen titel der sendung heißt
was die macht mit uns man und da gibt es
einen berühmten englischen historiker
lord acton und der wird immer wieder
zitiert der sache gab gesagt die macht
korrumpiert oder tendiert dazu und
absolute macht korrumpiert absolut
stimmt das denn psychologisch sie haben
ja auch psychologie studiert macht die
macht uns zu schlechteren menschen
das klingt jetzt auf den ersten blick
oder beim ersten hören
absolut zutreffend und plausibel dass
natürlich auch das anwachsen von
fähigkeiten jetzt im hebräischen schema
andere dazu zu bringen etwas zu tun dass
das anwachsen dieser fähigkeit selber
zur missbräuchlichkeit verführt und wenn
man eine bestimmte art von
anthropologischer prämisse hat das zum
beispiel die menschen macht nie genug
bekommen können
dann klingt das ja so dass man sagen
würden ja dann müssen wir aufpassen dass
die macht nicht an einer stelle sich
sobald sich so monopolisiert dass dann
die die sie haben wird ihr alles
mögliche machen können das ist sicher
richtig ich glaube man sollte ist aber
zusammen denken mit einem anderen
gedanken dass die macht natürlich auch
befähigt das heißt der ohnmächtige ist
auch in einem gewissen sinne nicht
korrumpiert aber eingeschränkt weil er
kann bestimmte dinge nicht tun und daher
merkt man auch hier ist wahrscheinlich
ein spektrum das wäre komisch zu sagen
wir wollen keine macht weil die macht
korrumpieren können wir wollen aber
natürlich nicht sagen wir brauchen
unbegrenzt macht sondern es könnte sein
dass es wahrscheinlich eine ökologische
frage dass ein bestimmtes maß an
und eine bestimmte verfügung über
bestimmte machtmittel für das
menschliche funktionieren und das gute
funktionieren das gute leben absolut
notwendig und unverzichtbar sind für die
für die freiheit oder verantwortung sehr
viel weil sie ja vielleicht ist ja
nichts und er kann noch nicht mal
korrumpiert werden aber das ist nichts
gutes keine unschuld sondern sozusagen
ein defekt an den effizienten deswegen
die ohne wichtigkeit ist für uns ja auch
ein problem nicht nur die korruption
aber trotzdem scheint es mir richtig
dass das übermäßige verfügen über
machtmittel auf jeden fall folgen gehabt
auch für das selbstbild von personen das
ist das was echten meint er würde sagen
die politiker die sich selber als die
bestimmer oder als die regierer
verstehen verlieren aus dem auge dass
sie für und mit anderen agieren und mit
anderen agieren müssten
und deswegen gibt es hier wahrscheinlich
eine psychologisch gesehen eine
korruptions tenöre mit produktions
verführung aber die ist nicht absolut
also es ist nicht das problem der macht
dass sie korrumpiert sondern das ausmaß
ist der kontext und natürlich einen
politischen fall der fehlenden kontrolle
die gut kontrollierte macht ist nicht
kopierbar sondern die kontrolle
verhindert das kopierte also ist die
macht dort in einer form in der sie sein
muss deswegen geben wir bestimmten
politischen akteuren mehr macht über
bestimmte entscheidungen werden darin
wollen aber das ist ringsherum andere
sagen wir mal gegen möchte gibt
kontrollrechte bestreitung möchte
und damit sind wir ja auch schon bei der
idee dass ich wahrscheinlich möchte
macht vom nacht konnte auch gegenseitig
in schach halten können und im guten
fall balancieren können kontrollieren
können im schlechten fall verklumpen
können so tatsächlich dem was dann
absolute macht oder übermaß an macht
heißen könnte
darüber werden wir sicher sprechen den
politischen kontext militärmacht
verteilt bilden so dass verschiedene
akteure jetzt diese anziehungskraft der
macht was weiß man über diese macht
menschen über diejenigen dieser erotik
der macht vielleicht auch verfallen sind
sind männer da gefährdete aus frauensee
narzisstische personen
das sind dann so die alltags
psychologischen beobachtungen die man
gerne hätten
das ist sicher richtig aber sagen jetzt
mal so dass die männer gerne ihre macht
ausspielen und sie leben liegt
wahrscheinlich nicht nur daran dass
männer ebenso sind sondern das liegt an
einer gesellschaft in der die mächte und
die handlungsfähigkeit auf eine
bestimmte weise verteilt sind und
übrigens ob sie das worden mögen oder
nicht in einer immer noch quasi
patriarchalen gesellschaft haben männer
anderer systematisch anders definierte
position im machtgefüge im
gesellschaftlichen machtgefühl wird das
heißt dass dort für die menge die macht
sozusagen er verfügbar ist
in dem sind aber auch er korrumpierbar
wirken können scheint mir richtig und
damit will ich jetzt auch gar keine
verantwortung von irgendjemandem
abziehen aber das scheint mir eher sagen
wir mal ein soziales soziologisches
phänomen zu sein als ein psychologisches
oder 1 das sogar in der natur der männer
oder so verantwort verantwortbarer
vereinbar wäre
und deswegen würde ich ja sagen die
psychologisch oder auch die
anthropologische ebene sollte eigentlich
immer begleitet sein komplementiert
seien durch eine soziologische analyse
die dann gar nicht so fragt was will
hier der einzelne wirklich oder in
seinem inneren sondern der er fragt was
sind gesellschaftliche bedingungen aber
auch gesellschaftliche verteilung und so
die dann zu stören dass männer richter
ist anders entscheiden und wenn man so
darüber nachdenkt interessiert man sich
natürlich eher für die ungleich
verteilte machen interessiert sich
kritisch dafür wenn man will sehen dass
unsere gesellschaften gar nicht einfach
nur aus normalen menschen die alle mehr
oder minder gleich sind bestehen obwohl
unsere grundgesetze das natürlich
behaupten sondern das aus sozialen
gründen ist relativ viele warnungen
strukturierungen teilungen und auch
separierung vorgenommen werden
die zum beispiel an dem punkt
tatsächlich die männer und die frauen
unterscheiden aber nicht in ihrem so
oder so sollen sondern in ihrer
handlungsfähigkeit und damit auch in
ihrer wichtigkeit und das ist selbst
ernannten könnte man sagen
sozialkritisches thema und nicht nur ein
psychologisches sie psychologische
dimension scheint mir ein teil davon zu
sein aber interessanter wird es glaube
ich wenn man das gesellschaftlich
betracht gesellschaftliche englisch
gelernt
wir haben im vorfeld der sendung mit
jemanden gesprochen der wirklich macht
hat oder macht hatte nämlich mit alt
bundesrat moritz leuenberger der war 15
jahre lang bundesrat und ich habe ihn
gefragt ob er in die politik gegangen
ist und dann bundesrat geworden ist auch
darum weil er mehr macht heute hat es
kurz ein politiker der von sich
behauptet er suche nicht die macht ist
ein verantwortungsloser politiker ich
kenne das so viele sagen ich und mache
ich bin nur kantonsrat in tat und
wahrheit ist er eher kantonsrat weile
einfluss haben will er sucht die macht
und der bundesrat werden will ohnehin
und es gehört eben auch dazu dass man
sich sein machtbewusstsein muss man muss
mit der macht verantwortungsvoll umgehen
und werde sie verneint tut das nicht wir
hatten die macht sich persönlich
verändert also am liebsten würde ich
sagen ich bin immer noch derselbe wie
immer aber es wäre gelogen
nur kann ich nicht so genau sagen was
sich bei mir verändert hat allein die
medienpräsenz allein dass ich mich heute
dazu äußern kann ist auch wieder eine
art von einflussnahme eine art macht und
das verändert einem vielleicht im
auftreten auch nicht nur gegenüber
fernsehmitarbeiter sondern auch im traum
und so weiter ich weiß es nicht genau
man muss natürlich aufpassen dass man
sich nicht an die macht gewöhnt sonst
wird man arrogant es gibt ja so was wie
unterschiedliche stile strategien der
machtausübung was ist denn ihr
persönlicher stil
das schweizerische system konditioniert
uns natürlich oder also wer bei uns
sagen wir im bundesrat beauftragt und
arrogant eine machtteilung sucht der ist
zum scheitern verurteilt
ich habe zum beispiel meinte parlament
als ich begann da hatte es energie und
verkehr sonst nichts dann habe ich mit
der zeit in umwelt raumplanung den
straßenverkauf dazu genommen
jedes mal habe ich mich ja wenn ihr mir
person bedingt geben wollte ich lass
mich schon über stimmen aber ich bin
natürlich nicht gegangen sind ich will
die umwelt hat sonst hätte ich sie
bekommen also unser system konditioniert
mit einem etwas manchmal an die grenze
des rechnerischen
gehenden verhaltens um die macht
effektiv erweitern zu können
bescheidenheit aus mitteln der macht was
sagen sie dazu
er ist ja ein richtiger philosophie der
sagt bescheidenheit ist hier der
richtige umgang sagt im selben moment
das ist manchmal nur eine fassade
heuchelei an die grenze der lage sagte
und das ist das ist starker weil er als
praktiker der macht selber sie dass der
umgang mit der macht eine sehr reelle
objektive seite hat aber auch eine
taktische strategische das heißt hier
geht es auch um anscheinend hier geht es
auch um den anschein erwecken können
auch im anblick der oder gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit gegenüber den medien aber
auch natürlich gegenüber dem wahlvolk
und da zeigt sich eine gewisse art von
doppelklick gültigkeit bei eben die mir
auch für die so fisch enorm produktiv
erscheint dass die macht seiner mal in
einem gewissen sind perspektivisch ist
dh sie hat etwas reales max weber hatte
recht es gibt die realen chancen
möglichkeiten ressourcen die macht zu
haben
zu ergreifen und umzusetzen darüber
redet er auch nur die alten hasen im
parlament wissen wie man bestimmte dinge
durchbringt aber es gibt jetzt auch
etwas schwerer greifbares der macht
zuschreibung und auch der der scheine
haften sollte der mache das ist die aber
die valencianer seitz der bloße anschein
der macht verleiht man aber jeder das
gegenteil zu viel davon ist nämlich
guten bestimmten kulturen und das ist
wahrscheinlich jetzt auch ein sehr guter
kommentare fast sogar eine richtige
analyse schon des politischen systems in
dem reale objektive macht über die
tatsächlich akteure verfügen im spiel
ist aber gleichzeitig durch sagen wir
mal virtuelle macht schein hafte macht
auch gesteigert werden kann
und das ist ein faszinierendes phänomen
dass hier leute macht haben aber was die
macht genau bedeutet wie man sie
einsetzen kann vermittelt ist mit dem
was die anderen glauben was die macht
sei oder sein könnte und dass hier ganz
oft auch illusion und projektionen im
spiel sind und wir alle würden
wahrscheinlich glauben die bundesräte
haben sehr viel mehr macht als sehr
viele andere
wenn man genauer hin kommt jetzt auch
sagen wir mal in der richtigen haben das
sozial theoretischen analyse würde man
natürlich sagen die sind auch in einem
gewissen sinn in bestimmten zwängen
gefangenen konditionierung ist das wort
das er verwendet die tatsächlich auch
diese spielräume wieder einengen und es
gibt wahrscheinlich noch sehr viele
andere macht akteure und macht
institutionen die das politische system
mindestens so stark bestimmen wie die
real existierenden parlamentarischen
akteure doch dafür hat er eine
interessante sprache gefunden mit dieser
idee es darf nicht so aussehen als
hätten bestimmte leute genau hier die
möglichkeit bestimmte entscheidungen
durchzusetzen und das scheint mir auch
richtig also das müsste man für die
einzelfälle dann nochmal genauer
beschreiben und es gibt deutliche
unterschiede zwischen den personen noch
zwischen den generationen in dem punkt
das ist auch ganz klar das ist so sagen
altgediente politiker der weiß mehr über
dieses ist eben als andere
und trotzdem gibt es hier auch in dem
moment sozusagen vom kontinent sagen
mama oder ambivalenzen siege sind das
heißt hier ist was unter bestimmt die
macht bestimmt nicht das ganze sondern
auch lässt spielräume offen und lässt
damit optionen offen
manchmal gar nicht so klar dingfest zu
machen sind wir versuchen dass gegen
ende der sendung noch mal aufs
politische zurückzukommen
jetzt interessiert mich nochmal die was
die großen philosophen eigentlich zu der
marke gesagt haben ich möchte zwar
erstmal rauspicken nämlich friedrich
nietzsche und spätrömische foucault und
bei nietzsche gibt es ja diesen gedanken
des willens zur macht der alles treibt
der im untergrund wirkt und selbst bei
der moral sagte er
stichwort sklaven moral also moral ist
eine erfindung der schwächeren oben
nicht unterdrückt er zu werden
können sie das erläutern ist das
plausibel überhaupt anzunehmen das so zu
sehen dass hinter dem streben nach dem
guten selbst wieder ein streben nach
macht ja das ist einer der
interessantesten unserer schillerndsten
gedanken in nietzsches genereller macht
philosophie auf nietzsche habe ich eben
schon mal kurz angespielt mit dieser
idee des virtuellen und das garnicht
objektiven oder greifbaren der macht
weil nietzsche selber unterscheidet
zwischen verschiedenen macht
bestrebungen und dem was er das
machtgefühl nennt von dem er festhält
dass das komplette real sein kann das
heißt die sachen können sich für stark
halten und umgekehrt
und auch das hat dann effekte für die
soziale welt in der sie auftreten als
scheinbar starke oder scheinbar schwache
aber hier gibt es im moment von realität
oder virtualität oder potenzial ead
sagen wir mal wer dann aber zurück wirkt
in der landtechnik und der auch wie bei
den bundesrat zurück wirkt auf die
subjektivität die selbst bilder und vor
diesem hintergrund also nie gesagt die
macht es immer im spiel auch eine
gewisse art von macht streben und diese
bisschen berüchtigte formel von willen
zur macht oder den willen zur macht hat
ja ich meistens gesagt im plural scheint
ja darauf hinzuweisen dass etwas tief
verankertes ist in der subjektivität
das stimmt aber gleichzeitig würde eher
sagen wie sich dieser wille oder diese
willen zur macht aus agieren oder
artikulieren hat auch selber wieder
etwas nicht objektives und deswegen ist
jetzt für ihn der gedanke wichtig die
moral die sich ja manchmal präsentiert
als reine objektivität reine unschuld
rein guter wille nach kant ist für
nietzsche selber etwas was man besser
versteht wenn man es auch als teil einer
artikulation des eigenen machtstrebens
aber auch der eigene macht zu schreiben
versteht und im rahmen seiner
religionskritik die wenn man so wie die
die grundlage die matrix seiner moral
kritik ist
wollte er nachweisen und die experten
streiten sich bis heute ob das gelungen
deshalb das nicht selber eine
spekulative idee ist dass auch der der
sich für absoluten macht frei erklärt
genau darin in dieser geste selber eine
art von machtposition besitzt eben keine
körperliche kann reale keine politische
aber man könnte sagen eine spirituelle
und in der moral ist für ihn genau das
am werk die die sagen wir sind hier die
die auf der seite der unparteilichkeit
oder des nicht eigens stehen stilisieren
sich selber damit als irgendjemand mit
einem bestimmten wert und auch darin
zeigt sich eine form von machtausübung
das ist die typische thesen und die ist
jetzt vielleicht weniger schrill und
auch weniger negativ oder realistische
realistisch als sie auf den ersten blick
klingen könnte wenn man würde ja denken
was soll das heißen
dann gibt's ja gar keine moral mehr gar
keine objektiven wert das ist weniger
gar nicht die entscheidende konsequenz
die insolvenz ist für ihn
wir müssen über die moral und auch über
so werte wie unparteilichkeit oder
gerechtigkeit im kontext der leben
sprechen in denen sie angerufen
etabliert und verteidigt werden
das heißt hinter jedem moral theoretiker
steckt auch eine person die der moral
theoretiker ist hinter jedem der sich
selber für einen guten menschen erklären
steckt eine person die ein bestimmtes
leben führt mit anderen die in diesem
gefüge mit anderen rollen spielt und
wirkung gezeitigt
und damit gibt es für mieter er den
versuch nochmal einer psychologischen
abklärung dieser großen ideale täter
oder dieser vorstellung die moral seiner
machtfragen enthoben oder valley dinge
näher aneinander
nicht um sie ineinander kollabieren zu
lassen die zeit viel zu viel respekt vor
den werten um sie als bloße macht zu
beschreiben aber er will sagen die werte
sind nie ohne macht und auch nie ohne
macht streben und selbst jedes
programmieren von werten ist selber
sagen wir mal eine machtvolle geste eine
machtvolle artikulation oder selber der
versuch
sich als einen ganz bestimmten eine ganz
bestimmte darzustellen und auch das soll
wirkungen haben und ist damit in diesem
ganz allgemein sind selber ein macht
phänomen und das scheint mir
philosophisch plausibel und übrigens
auch für alle unsere kontext in dem wir
auch im rahmen der politischen fragen
natürlich reden über was sind die besten
orientierung wurde woraufhin sollten wir
uns orientieren sollte das noch alle
spielen dass wir immer mal wieder auch
die relativierung der reihen werte oder
ein normen auf die persönlichkeiten und
die realen diese skepsis
angedacht ist dass die moore haben die
gerechtigkeit vielleicht auch ein bloßer
vorwand ist vielleicht eine ideologie
stichwort kolonialismus imperialismus
geopolitischen hinter der wichtigen
politischen entscheidungen und das zeigt
ich meine michael succow wird sich dann
später auf nietzsche auch nach beziehen
und diesen gedanken aufgreifen dass die
macht aus durchdringt und selbst in
unsere köpfe und herzen hineingeht und
bestimmt wie wir denken wollen und und
fühlen und michal foucault war sagt er
gesagt hat macht ist nicht nur
verhindern sondern sie haben das gesagt
ist nach produkten kann dinge entstehen
lassen ist die damit auch etwas etwas
gutes oder hält sollte man sich mit
diesem werturteilen in ihrer meinung
nach eher zurückhaltend erst mal
beschreiben wenn ich selber die
intervention von foucault richtig
verstehe hätte ich ja gedacht dass er
sagt wir können alle möglichen wertungen
wieder einziehen
aber wir sollten nicht mit ihnen
beginnen und ich glaube wie liter sagt
er wir sollten realisten sollen und erst
mal versuchen die mächte die machtmittel
die macht streben in ihrem jeweiligen
sozialen und persönlichen und
psychologischen kontext beschreiben um
dann später über die effekte der macht
selbst auf die personen und auf die
gesellschaft zu reden
und am ende des tages würde auch foto
nicht zulassen dass es mehr oder minder
obsessive form politischer
organisationen oder soziale
einrichtungen gibt das wäre ab sodass zu
leugnen wo leben das der möglichen leute
immer mal vorwerfen aber die
philosophische oder methodische lektion
die er
einbringen wollte war er lasst uns nicht
mit den wertungen beginnen und nicht mit
der guten oder schlechten macht als
vorausgesetzte unterscheidung operieren
sondern erstmal das funktionieren der
macht das wirken der macht bisher
doppelt gemoppelt ausgedrückt beginnen
um dann zu sehen was die mögliche
kartographierung dieser effekte oder
wirkung tatsächlich uns auch bedeutet
und politisch bedeutet und auch
moralisch
das heißt dann wird es immer noch
möglich zu sagen bestimmte institutionen
haben ein problem bestimmte gesetze sind
falsch bestimmte politische bewegung
sind hier deutlicher weise zwangshaft
oder ob receive aber das ist nichts was
von vorhinein in den begriffen schon
liegt oder in unserer großen
beschreibung der fans kommt die macht
analyse genau ich dann die die bewertung
und bei findet man ja ganz verschiedene
begriffe man befindet disziplin ahmann
sind pastor 1 8 bio macht micro physik
der macht glaubt er denn es gibt ganz
verschiedene arten vom macht oder
letztlich nur eine und verschiedene
ausprägungen die sicherheit begriffe die
sie jetzt zitiert haben zeigen ja an
dass er die sache historisch denkt dass
er sagen würde macht ganz allgemein
existiert ohnehin nicht weil sie ist ja
selber vielgestaltig und er hatte die
these dass sich macht formen oder macht
typen herausbilden die für spezifische
epochen und spezifische gesellschaften
dann charakteristisch können sie
vielleicht 102 davon kurz erläutern dass
wir das verstehen was die von disziplin
da macht spricht er im kontext vor allem
des siebzehnten und achtzehnten
jahrhunderts und es geht für ihn bis ins
19 jahrhundert er sagt in der bestimmten
epoche der europäischen geschichte
konzentrieren sich bestimmte form von
institution um das disziplinieren das
heißt dass gefügig machen und ausnutzen
von körpern
das heißt unterhalb der ebene der
politischen organisationen da gibt es
könige obrigkeiten aristokratie gibt es
ein neues system historisch neu das auch
mit dem beginnenden komplettes muss
zusammenfällt dass jetzt tatsächlich
körper nutzbar macht und sie dem
gewissen sinn bewirtschaftet und
disziplin ist für ihn der name für die
verschiedenen techniken die jetzt
versuchen
körper nicht bürger sondern körper
produktivkräfte gewissermaßen zu nutzen
und damit aber auch zu kontrollieren den
schach zu halten
zu disziplinieren gefängnisse zum
beispiel von bayers beispiel aus den
sicheren die gefängnisse sind für ihn
die paradigmen dh die phänomene an den
some deutlich sind wir dabei würde sagen
in dieser zeit bildet sich am
gesellschaftshaus in der alles mögliche
so organisiert dass strukturell in der
gewisse analogie wie gefängnisse das
heißt auch schulen haben bestimmte
produktivitäts standard bestimmte
messungen bestimmte prüfungen bestimmte
ergebnisse und deswegen wollte schon
immer mal wieder für bestimmte epochen
den spezifischen macht typus beschreiben
und diese begriffe diese dynamische oder
pastoral macht oder das was er später
auch mal gewinner mentalität genannt hat
sind für ihn solche epochen begriffe in
denen zusammen schießt das
vielgestaltige gesellschaftliche macht
in bestimmten zeiten nach einem
bestimmten schema seine bestimmten logik
oder dem muster verfährt übrigens ein
gedanke der bei foucault enorm nahe an
oder eng an marx entlang gedacht ist
wenn auch marx hatte diese idee dass die
macht des kapitals in einer bestimmten
zeit alle gesellschaftlichen
verhältnisse projekt und auf eine
bestimmte weise konfiguriert und focus
sagte die marktanalyse ist richtig aber
sie war viel zu eingeschränkt auf eine
bestimmte gesellschaftliche sphäre wir
müssen eher verstehen dass die
unterschiedlichen gesellschaftlichen
bereiche selber jeweils analog in ihrer
macht wirkung oder innere macht typus
organisiert sind und die heutigen
analysen die mit dem begriff des
neoliberalismus argumentieren versuchen
dass wir in so eine art zusammenführung
von macht von foucault und marx auch für
unsere heutige welt zu beschreiben ich
habe jetzt eben gerade an heute denken
müssen was sie gesagt haben diese diese
körper fixierungen zum beispiel dieses
messen also stichwort brand die
vereinsehrungen
ist alles und das ist so ein körper
kohls der bitte betrieben wird kann man
das mit foucault besonders gut erklären
was wir unseren körper so dermaßen
disziplinieren
natürlich das interessante bei foucault
ist jetzt dass er sagt dass es gar nicht
so ist sondern das ist eigentlich eine
kulturelle oder soziale technik die
ziemlich alt ist nämlich 250 100 und er
würde jetzt natürlich sagen die
richtigen neoliberalismus hat er ohnehin
nicht mehr erlebt dass 84 gestorben
aber der würde sagen das hat sich
inzwischen mit anderen motiven
angereichert und da wird schon von der
psychologie hatten würde ich auch sagen
die macht heute ist sicher auch körper
vermittelt und wir messen und optimieren
die ganze zeit körperliche funktionen
von der schlaue nur bis zum
hochleistungssport aber wir haben
natürlich auch andere eher psychisch
werden der imaginäre wirken effektiv
wirkende macht formen wie wir uns selber
präsentieren darstellen ver bildern und
auch das sind natürlich teile der
derzeitigen macht konfiguration die
jetzt alle auf die körperlichkeit
zurückzuführen wahrscheinlich ganz ganz
unterkomplex wäre
und auch das ist für mich der
koreanische lektion dass wir die
vielheit oder die pluralität von macht
wirkungen versuchen sollten in der
analyse zu bündeln
aber ohne sie zu reduzieren das heißt
zulassen dass die macht vielfältig
vielgestaltig ist sozusagen eine multi
pecik von formen annimmt die aber
manchmal eine gewisse einheitliche logik
raten ob das eine logik der steigerung
der abschöpfung oder der ausbeutung ist
ist jetzt eine frage der konkreten
analyse und die neoliberalismus analysen
sind sich ja auch zur zeit finde ich gar
nicht so einig was hier die haupt logik
ist aber zu behaupten die gesellschaft
ist macht förmlich strukturiert aber auf
vielgestaltige weise im familiären
anders als den beruflichen aber trotzdem
wirken diese verschiedenen
strukturierungen zusammen
das ist finde ich der faszinierende und
eigentlich auch was die foucault wirkung
angeht und abgegolten gedanke das muss
jede generation neu machen und wo ist
hier ein vorbild aber gar nicht die
lösung
ich meine es gibt diese
unterschiedlichen formen der
machtausübung angesprochen und es gibt
diese einfache unterscheidung zwischen
hard power soft power im politischen des
einstigen wieder mit gewalt mit mit
militär und das andere mit mit kultur
mit subtiler unterschwelliger
beeinflussung und da habe ich mir die
frage gestellt ist eigentlich macht dann
am effektivsten wenn er sich gar nicht
spüren wenn wir anfangen die dinge
selbst zu wollen und selbst
kontrollieren disziplinen
denn sicher so dass nicht wie zwang
anfühlt sondern wie freiheit richtig und
das war ein gedanke der fokus immer
enorm fasziniert hat das macht wie
freiheit aussehen kann vielleicht sogar
macht als freiheit auftritt und seine
analysen des liberalismus jetzt auch
dass der historischen konfiguration aus
dem 18 jahrhundert ging in diese
richtung und das ist ein gedanke der
auch bei dem anderen meiner lieblings
philosophen relativ große rolle spielt
spinosa hat im 17 jahrhundert mal über
die monarchische macht gesagt sie ist
dann am effektivsten wenn die leute die
menschen für ihre unterwerfung kämpfen
als sei sie ihr heil in seltsame
formulierung die aber tatsächlich auch
zeit diagnostischen sprengkraft hat denn
das soll er heißen
manchmal ist genau das die praxis der
bereich in dem man glaubt sich selbst zu
befreien oder zu verwirklichen
der bereich in dem man der macht am
tiefsten unterliegen und wie weiß mal
was was da fakt ist aber dass wirklich
freiheit ist oder es zwar angenommen
die philosophin sagen nur das kann
vorkommen und es ist jetzt auch wieder
mal eine frage der konkreten
gesellschafts theoretischen analyse
diese phänomene aufzuzeigen
aber wir haben natürlich diese phänomene
der bestimmte art der selbst
thematisierung der selbstpräsentation
im ersten moment wie absolute freiheit
über sich selbst sich selbst
präsentieren können auf eine bestimmte
weise wirkte erstmal sowie eine freie
persönlichkeitsentfaltung
wenn jetzt eine analyse zeigen kann dass
das selber in rastern passiert auch
unter ökonomischen bedingten und
bedingungen und über die sozialen medien
könnten wir jetzt lange reden
die selber eigentlich die form in der
sich das selbst präsentiert so der
terminieren dass hier nichts mehr frei
ist sondern sehr viel sein wort
konditioniert oder determiniert ist dann
haben wir so ein fall
und dann gibt es leute die verteidigen
diese absolute freiheit genau dieser
form sich zu präsentieren als sei es ihr
heil und in wirklichkeit verstärken sie
damit noch und zusagen vertiefen noch
die macht wirkungen die er jetzt eine
macht des diskurses eine macht der
definierten selbstbilder und natürlich
auch die macht bestimmte ökonomische
akteure interessen ist und das sind die
interessanten firmware in denen die
macht selber zum ambivalenten in sich
zwischen macht und freiheit verschaffte
phänomen
ich finde man kann ich habe sogar nach
müssen weiter reden und sagen freiheit
nach kant ist autonomie selbst
gesetzgebung heißt auch irgendwie sich
selbst zu beherrschen seine trieb ist
eine momentan neigung vielleicht ist
freiheit der herrschaft über sich selbst
auf jeden fall
das ist ein gedanke der jetzt auch bei
den autoren der tradition in der ich
selber stehe und das relativ große rolle
gespielt die these von der dialektik der
aufklärung von könnte und adorno hatte
diesen kern dass die aufklärungs moral
das autonomie bestreben der zentrale
werte europäischen aufklärung und
moderne selber in sich ein repressives
seite hat sagen
der repressive dimensionen und das zur
freiheit auch eine art von
selbstkontrolle selbst kontrollieren und
vielleicht sogar selbst beschneidung
gehört auch ein gedanke der im rahmen
der philosophischen arbeiten relativ
spekulativen charakter hat und auch die
direkte aufklärung das buch in dem
dieser gedanke formuliert wird
präsentiert sich nicht wirklich selber
als jetzt eine sozial theoretische
analyse aber ich glaube man kann ihnen
diesen gedanken tatsächlich in der
konkreten analyse auch erhärten und
belegen das ziel ist es hier tatsächlich
gibt es voraussetzungen der freiheit die
selber unfall sind und unfrei macht nur
der der sich selber zur freiheit
beschneidet kann frei sein und das sind
diese paradoxe und ambivalenten
phänomene von denen ich glaube dass sie
eigentlich im herzen einer philosophie
der macht stehen sollten
aber das darf nicht nur eine native idee
sein sondern man muss jetzt an konkreten
praktiken im konkreten auch
gesellschaftliche institutionen und
verhältnissen zeigen wie das heute für
uns genau sich ausspielt und da stimmt
genau das wollen jetzt ein bisschen
machen blick aufs politische es gibt die
these des britischen
politikwissenschaftlers colin crouch der
sagt wir leben gar nicht in demokratien
sondern mit leben in postdemokratie in
scheindemokratie es gibt eben zu viele
faktoren wie geld und so weiter die ihr
damit hineinspielen und den eigentlich
demokratischen gedanken untergraben will
das heißt die macht kommt irgendwie von
über anders aber nicht mehr vom volk
stimmt das crouch hatte enorm
schlagkräftige analyse bestimmter
probleme unserer real existierende
demokratien geliefert und der begriff
der postdemokratie den er verwendet hat
wie übrigens auch das heer der übrigens
sogar ein bisschen früher ist hier
glaube ich absolut einschlägig und
hilfreich ob es genau stimmt dass wir
nicht mehr in demokratien sondern im
tross demokratie in den verhältnissen
nach der demokratie leben
das halte ich jetzt für zweifelhaft aber
das hängt jetzt ein bisschen noch davon
ab wie man diesen begriff versteht aber
coach hat reicht die machtgefüge die
machtoption haben sich verschoben und
manchmal wird das ist eine these mehr in
den hinterzimmern mehr von den spinden
mehr von der wirtschaft entschieden als
von den eigentlich zum politischen
handeln autorisierten personen zum
beispiel den parlamenten oder auch den
parteien und crouch hat leider leicht
nostalgischen zug und er suggeriert als
ob sich heile welt der 50er 60er 70er
jahre gegeben hätte in der diese
demokratie noch ganz lebendig war und
jetzt ist sie plötzlich fast in
auflösung begriffen das scheint mir auch
über historisch fast eine falsche
vorstellungen vom guten zustand der
demokratie gewesen zu sein aber er hat
recht die gefüge haben sich verschoben
neue akteure die nicht immer die der
autorisierten offiziellen politik sind
bestimmen in unserer heutigen demokratie
wahrscheinlich viel mehr mit als je
zuvor und das ist deswegen reden wir
drüber
das problem denn wenn die demokratie die
herrschaft unter die macht des volkes
bedeutet ist natürlich jeder nachweis
dass die macht des volkes verschwindend
geringes gegenüber nach der macht derer
die die politik orchestrieren
ein skandal und deswegen ist zu recht
der branche weckruf übrigens vielleicht
ist das gar keine demokratie mehr als so
drastisch und skandalös wahrgenommen
worden und trotzdem stimmen wir alle zu
dass unsere politischen gefüge in der
tat zu zeiten der transformation
durchlaufen
in der wahrscheinlich die autorisierung
eigentlich nicht demokratisch
autorisierter machtgruppen die
eigentliche der gefahr darstellt dann
krisenphänomen aber das scheint das
zentrum sagen wir mal des problems
politische handlungsfähigkeit unter
demokratischen bedingungen
das ist auch der welt was viele
populisten auch so ähnlich sagen würden
und deswegen hat man auch den eindruck
viele demokratien sind in der krise und
die schweiz gilt für viele als vorzeige
demokratie brauchen natürlich
und wir haben im vorfeld mit moritz
leuenberger natürlich auch über die
schweiz gesprochen und ihn gefragt wer
denn eigentlich die macht hat in der
schweiz
es gibt ein ideal in der
bundesverfassung zurückgeschrieben
nämlich dass die stimmbürgerinnen und
stimmbürger zusammen mit den kantonen
die macht haben
das ist letztlich eine utopie weil jeder
stimmbürger stimmbürgerinnen aber auch
jeder parlamentarier bis hin zur
mitglieder der regierung sind
beeinflussbar beeinflussbar von
meinungsmachern die ihrerseits wieder
geld haben beeinflussbar vielleicht auch
von den sozialen medien vielleicht auch
manipulierbar und diese macht die sehr
komplex verwoben ist genau zu definieren
wo welche macht ist gegenstand ständiger
politischen diskussion wie beurteilen
sie denn die macht der wirtschaft und
des geldes in der schweiz
wer geld hat macht und hat damit
einfluss die wirtschaft das müssen wir
etwas breit sein auch die gewerkschaften
gehören zur wirtschaft auch sie üben
macht aus wie wir jetzt beim
rahmenabkommen ja auch es sehen
geld spielt auf jeden fall eine wichtige
rolle deswegen die stetige forderung
nach transparenz die in der schweiz
schlechter geregelt ist als in anderen
ländern parteienfinanzierung
hier liegt vieles im dunkeln und
deswegen sind auch die tatsächlichen
einflussnahmen von mächtigen kreisen
ihnen verborgen
die schweiz ist ein vergleichsweise
kleines land international vernetzt
überschätzt sie ihre eigene macht es
gibt keine menschen die vollkommen
autonom sind wie wir sind alle abhängig
von der familie von denen arbeitgebern
vor unserer umgebung das ist bei einem
land nicht anders wir sind eingebettet
in eine globale wirtschaft wir sind von
nachbarn umgeben die haben alle einfluss
auf unser land und dessen sollten wir
uns bewusst sein
in der politik gibt es auch ein
bundesrat das parlament und die kantone
wiesen jetzt die macht in der politik
genau verteilt
wir haben eine regierung mit kollegial
system wo also alle sich irgendwie
finden müssen
wir haben das rotationsprinzip also
bundespräsident ist man ein jahr lang
jeder kommissionspräsident muss nach
einer gewissen zeit wieder gehen also so
langsam wird darauf geachtet dass sich
die macht nicht an einem ort an bald
genau die macht scheint gut verteilt zu
sein sagt moritz leuenberger in der
schweiz ist das nicht aber auch eine
gefahr man kann ja sagen wenn niemand
mehr klarerweise die macht hat dann
geschieht so etwas wie
handlungsunfähigkeit eine ohnmacht
man kann nicht mehr entscheiden und so
war glaube ich dass der soziologe niklas
luhmann der gesagt hat macht entlastet
da hilft uns entscheidungen zu treffen
das ganze wird sonst einfach zu lang zu
lassen
es gibt diesen starken zusammenhang
zwischen macht und handlungsfähigkeit
und deswegen ist tatsächlich natürlich
das verteilen von macht auch in
verteilen von handlungsfähigkeit
verteilung heißt natürlich auch
einschränkungen
in diesem sinn sind stark mächtige
akteure handlungsfähiger als andere oder
handlungsfähiger als systeme in denen
viele mit handeln
das ist richtig und deswegen gibt es für
bestimmte kontexte auch immer mal wieder
der ruf nach mehr zentralisierung
verklumpung verwaltung sondern wie auch
er spricht
aber die frage ist natürlich ob es nicht
relativ effektive systeme von verteilung
gelber und das gute bild der schweiz und
auch das haben hier ja vor lautet dass
es institutionelle gefüge geben kann die
die macht zwar verteilen aber
handlungsfähigkeit effektiv organisieren
diese balance halten kann und eine
gewisse form von demokratietheoretisch
umdenken hängt bisher mit dem der
ideengeschichte der usa zusammen mit dem
federal ist lief eigentlich so dass sich
die sie gegenseitig in schach halten den
kontrollierenden machtblöcke hoch
handlungsfähig sind sogar im ernstfall
aber es muss auf eine bestimmte
institutionelle weise eingerichtet sein
im zweifelsfall immer genau
sichergestellt ist wer wann handeln darf
und wer danach kontrollieren darf die
diagnose hier lautet jetzt manchmal
diffundiert die macht auch und damit
auch die handlungsfähigkeit definiert
heißt hier nur sie ist auf eine weise
verteilt die die macht er verliert als
gut organisiert und steigert und auch
das scheint mir richtig also dass damit
noch mal klar wird dass machtverteilung
sehr gut eingerichtet sein muss mit sehr
vielen also wie schlau und
institutionellen mechanismen die immer
mal wieder das ineinandergreifen der
unterschiedlichen kontrollinstanzen auch
gewährleistet und die klage hier ist ja
und die hängt mit der korsischen
postdemokratie diagnose zusammen
das vielleicht unsere demokratien
zurzeit eine institutionelle krise
durchlaufen in denen diese alten
kontroll und wenn man so will dann
ineinander greifen ismen auf eine
gewisse art außer kraft gesetzt werden
durch neue starke akteure und auch für
ihn ist völlig klar
die ökonomischen interessen die
ökonomische macht drückt auf dieses
demokratische politische gefüge und
dieses verhalten ist es umgekehrt sagt
er auch das ist eine alte marxistischen
diagnose seit den 70er jahren dass die
massendemokratie problem haben mit den
nicht autorisierten
privatwirtschaftlichen akteuren deren
soziale macht ja absolut nicht zu
leugnen ist wer die macht hat das geld
sagt er und der beeinflusste auch der
rat auch die politischen
entscheidungsprozesse und hier könnte es
sein und ich finde unsere politische
debatte geht in die richtung zur zeit
hier haben wir das vertrauen verloren in
unserer alten institution und
mechanismen das klima sind dass diese
krise gerade ausgebrochen jetzt oder in
unseren köpfen angekommen ist hat dieser
vertrauensverlust den die eliten und in
die institution auch dieses gefühl von
ohnmacht angesichts der globalen politik
der globalisierung was machen wir denn
dagegen wir müssen es natürlich erst mal
richtig platzieren und richtig verstehen
weil diese diagnose des in die krise
geraten sei
der institutionellen gefüge ist eine
andere klage als die im zeitalter der
globalisierung könnte doch niemand mehr
handeln weil wir ohnehin von dem
weltmarkt abhängig werden wer ist denn
der weltmarkt und sind denn die
schweizer institution ich nenne nur die
schweizer banken nicht teil das
verhältnis und nicht teil der
definierung von dem was überhaupt
weltmarkt heißt ist die eu ein schwacher
akteure der gar nichts machen kann weil
er sich nach den wechselkursen in asien
richten muss irgendwie ja irgendwie nach
in weil wir haben institutionelle
reformen in denen genau diese dinge
besprochen verhandelt werden und wir
haben sehr viele informelle er soziale
er wirtschaftliche form von absprachen
und auch von verbannung von
einflussnahme und von macht die genau
diese dinge ja definieren und was wir
glaube ich zurzeit zurecht erleben ist
eine politisierung dieser frage und
politisierung heißt ja hier nur wir
diskutieren diese frage jetzt nicht nur
als ein schicksal sondern auch als eine
frage wer kann hier eigentlich gerade
noch handeln und das für uns jetzt
vielleicht beunruhigende ist dass diese
klage kommt von links und von rechts
beziehungsweise sie kommt von akteuren
die selber versuchen das als argument
gegen das herrschende system und die
sogenannten eliten in anschlag zu
bringen wo die populisten sind hier die
lauteste gruppe aber natürlich verbindet
sich das auch mit einer sehr ernsthaften
und auch sagen wir mal und
sozialwissenschaftlich fundierten
analyse die sagt das problem ist absolut
rehhagel
und tatsächlich ist das nachdenken über
macht und ohnmacht heute das heißt über
die verteilung von macht und
handlungsfähigkeit
dringendste die absolut dringendste
frage unserer gegenwart und selbst wenn
wir über dinge wie die ökologische krise
und über den klimawandel nach denken
denken wir ja politisch darüber nach das
heißt nicht alles was passiert hier und
was können wir gar nicht ändern sondern
wir könnten hier handlungsfähige akteure
sein und da ist die schülerin kreta
mindestens so ernst zu nehmen wie unsere
klimaexperten aber auch unsere
politischen autoritäten die sagen wir
haben noch gar nicht die richtigen
institution allen plattformen um solche
dinge im globalen maßstab an gehen
geschweige denn lösen zu können haben
klimawandel ist das eine digitalisierung
das große andere das irgendwie global
gelöst werden muss und die große macht
der digital konzerne google apple
facebook usw den ungeheures wissen haben
durch die daten die man irgendwie auch
bändigen muss jetzt politische wie sie
sagen
gegen wie geht es um die spielregeln ich
möchte mit ihnen nach dem missbrauch zu
sprechen kommen der entsteht wenn sich
die macht eben nicht verteilt nicht gut
verteilt ist und man sich bald und da
hatten wir jetzt den letzten wochen
diese diese medienberichte über die
übergriffe in der katholischen kirche
wie hatten vor ein zwei jahren die
methode button
wie ist ihre einschätzung die rolle der
beteiligten selbst macht verantwortung
oder der spielregeln bolik denn
eigentlich da der große fehler jetzt zum
beispiel in der katholischen kirche ist
das etwas das man leicht lösen kann oder
es liegt der fehler im system
ich bin heute keinen katholischen
würdenträger in dieser zeit
und selbst als ganz ganz entfernte
beobachter sehen wir wie es dort gärt
und wie in dieser institution gerade
intern gekämpft wird darum wer hier
verantwortung übernimmt damit aber auch
verantwortung für seine eigene macht
übernimmt und in welcher folgen das
heißt ich kann darüber jetzt im
speziellen gar nicht so viel sagen außer
dass es ein hervorragendes beispiel ist
von der macht krise und er macht krise
ist eine handlungsfähigkeit krise im
selben
und weil ungefragte autorität ist hier
tatsächlich abgeschmolzen das hat die
katholische kirche sogar noch in unseren
breiten relativ lange in anspruch nehmen
können
und prompt stellt sich die frage wie
kann man denn jetzt prestige vertrauen
gefolgschaft wiederherstellen und welche
arten von symbolischen und handfesten
aktionen können in diese richtung gehe
über diese frage zerstreitet sich
offensichtlich gerade der komplette
apparat und das ist jetzt von außen
gesehen enorm interessant und sogar
faszinierend aber man sieht natürlich
auch das ganze persönliche psychische
leid das leider in der stadt st
die ursache und ja auch der auslöser für
diese krise ist und da muss jetzt eine
institution sich wahrscheinlich weiß
nicht ob das seltsame wort vom neu
erfinden hier die richtige metapher ist
aber da muss sich auch jetzt gerade ein
gefüge seiner eigenen macht und auch
damit seiner zukunft neue versichern die
anderen skandalisierung sind so ähnlich
auch mit hat eine krise im
geschlechterverhältnis sichtbar gemacht
und auch eine ungleichverteilung der
strukturelle ungleichverteilung das wort
patriarch hatte habe ich schon verwendet
tatsächlich aufgezeigt an der stelle wo
viele gedacht hätten wir werden fünf
schritte weiter oder fünf schritte
egalitärer fünf schritte
gleichberechtigte oder fähre diese
krisen sind absolut symptomatisch und
ernst zu nehmen also da entdeckt
sozusagen die gesellschaft ihre eigene
krise heftigkeit und ihre eigenen macht
und ohnmachtsgefühle und das ist jetzt
für mich als philosoph ich habe ja zu
den konkreten fällen gar nicht so viel
zu sagen wie die akteure die müssen das
ja jetzt vorantreiben
die betroffenen vor allem sind hier
nicht nur der sprachrohr sondern
eigentlich auch die mitspielerinnen und
mitspieler dieser neue bestimmung auch
der zukunft dieser institution oder
dieser gesamten gesellschaftlichen
verhältnisse als philosoph kann man hier
nur zur kenntnis nehmen wie eng macht
und gesellschaftlich keit sich
gegenseitig sozusagen informieren
bestimmen sodass man doch mal sieht dass
gesellschaften nichts anderes sind als
machtgefüge und machtgefüge sind gefühl
geben denen der eine macht bekommt die
anderen sind nicht bekommen
verschiedenen verteilt wird ungleich
verteilt wird
manchmal sind es noch nicht mal akteure
denen wir das zu schreiben könnten sie
haben die digitalisierung erwähnen
manchmal gibt es technische macht macht
der technik macht das wissen
da sitzt zwar irgendwo vielleicht in
kalifornien oder im silicon valley
aber auch das hat was transportable das
virtuelle macht form die sind gar nicht
so verschraubt im an dem ort an dem sie
liegen jetzt muss ich meine macht
ausspielen er sei die stunde ist nämlich
zu ende
ich wusste ich musste fast schon und es
war sehr interessant und wenn wissen
tatsächlich macht ist dann bin ich jetzt
viel mächtiger swo dieser stunde fielen
haben das gespräch ganz herzlichen dank
ja und auch einen herzlichen dank fürs
fürs mit denk nächste woche spricht
barbara bleisch mit der star soziologin
eva illouz über die liebe in zeiten des
kapitalismus und fragt was übrig bleibt
wenn die liebe zu ende geht
und jetzt gleich folgt sternstunde kunst
mit deinen eindrücklichen zielen über
frida kahlo und diego rivera das
berühmteste künstler park mexikos und
ihre tiefe geheimnisvolle liebe bleiben
sie aus gram und einen sprung sonntag
[Musik]